demain le prix de l'arc de triomphe où
vous verrez bien entendu en direct et en
eurovision vers 16h15
c'est le championnat du monde des
chevaux de pure sans un nom un nom
célèbre je vais dire à mon illustre chez
tous ceux qui s'intéressent peu ou prou
cheval alex france qui appartient à
magnanville d'un stand de l'institut
allez france qui sera monté par xmap 1
lequel reste sur une chute très simple
et qui tout de même va remonter la
jument qu'il aime tant nous allons
d'abord voir comment aller france a
remporté l'une de ses victoires les plus
éblouissantes
c'était cette année dans le prix
d'ispahan à longchamp kazakh foncé top
clair la casaque de daniel wildenstein
elle est dernière à l'entrée d'une
grotte dernière à droite russe comme à
yves saint martin lui demande de venir
et cette jument prodigieuse va
littéralement dévoré tous les autres
elle va galoper deux fois plus vite que
regarder sans même que saint martin lui
demande de donner son maximum
elle les avale elle les efface comme si
d autres qui pourtant est de très bon ce
jour là n'existait pas nous sommes à les
retrouver sains et france à
l'entraînement
allez france d'une part la boissière
très bien et sa petite copine la ville
de ncell numéro 2 paulista qui est une
pouliche de 3 ans laquelle reste sur
quatre victoires consécutives alors à
l'eg8 d'un stand je le prenne à
l'entraîneur tout l'entourage est allé
voir les galops allez france là en
troisième position est très loin de
donner son maximum c'est un travail de
détente
juste pour permettre aux créateurs de 24
heures soit une de voir qu'elle va très
bien et derry rennes ce sera le gallo
2000 train le camp terre si vous ne
voulez de paulista laquelle des deux
gagnera en réalité il n'ya que
l'embarras du choix la mariée trop belle
mais que faut-il faire pour gagner l'arc
de triomphe et quelles sont les
influences du terrain par exemple et des
incidents de course c'est ce qu'on
demande à sa marque
il faut
tout se passe bien ça faut d'abord avoir
le cheval capable de gagner et ensuite
il faut qu'il y ait l'aptitude de
terrain d'un ciné pas forcé nous avions
le même terrain ce jour là juste en fin
de saison dans le monde octobre ont
souvent été un souper même parfois été
un lourd et les courses sélectives si
vous voulez tout au cours de cours toute
l'année son secours souvent l'été au
printemps la belle saison donc avec un
terrain généralement bon il se peut que
ce sans compter un gène certains chevaux
et il faut qu'il n'y ait pas de
bousculade il faut que que le train soit
il faut enfin se sont pas gênés par
d'autres concurrents se tient encore
différences entre eux qu'il faut qu'ils
sont nécessaires pour une chance
programme il y aura la grande foule
demain à longchamp voici une image de
mes dernières ou rheingold bâti allez
france elle avait trois ans à l'époque
un terrien deuxième de cet excellent
cheval le lot était plus touffu qui ne
le sera demain ils étaient 27
il y est l'année dernière elle portait
d'ailleurs le numéro 27
et vous allez l'avoir terminé 2e kazakh
foncé peau claire derrière rheingold
super rheingold qui ce jour-là courait
sa meilleure forme
allez france est améliorée sur l'année
dernière il semble que 74 soit pour elle
une année face elle est de quelques
livres comme l'on dit meilleure que ce
qu'elle était l'an passé ils ce matin
fait une chute il y a une dizaine de
jours en français qu'il ne monterait pas
aller france quel serait mon père
piggott
en réalité il semble qu'il aille bien si
les gens croient ce qu'il a dit à daniel
lauclair avec elle et pas lui rendre
visite dans sa villa de chantilly alliez
vous bien yves réflexion et réponse oui
effectivement j'ai fracture du grand
trochanter qu'il faisait lorsqu'il se
situant au dessus du fémur qui jeudi
dernier et depuis dimanche je suis
une rééducation qui me permet de rire -
souplesse et de moi souffrir les plus
aucun problème de mon côté on peut donc
rassuré tous les turfistes et j'ai honte
et une heure soit un hachage donc un lot
d'entraînement sans problème aucune
douleur aucune donc en forme pour le
jour j demain avec nous sur le plateau
guy wildenstein le fils du propriétaire
merci dividend ted d'être avec nous est
ce qu'on peut dire vraiment pour
restaurer le turfiste yves saint-martin
est au maximum de sa forme en tous les
cas qu'il est en très belle forme pour
demain vais vous dire je ne sais pas
s'il est au maximum de sa forme mais en
tout cas il est en pleine possession de
tous ses maux sinon nous n'aurions pas
laisser monter la joue et s'il ne la
joue on n'avait pas été montée par sama
pain beurré pp par un autre grand jockey
peut-être piggott qu'elle nous a répété
ses chances à ce moment là je crois
qu'elle a encore plus de chance avec un
yves saint martin un petit peu blessé
qu'avec un pilote qui ne la connaît pas
non pas à cause du jeu qu aimer par le
par le fait même qu'il ne connaît pas il
faut connaître du manque et un petit peu
difficile qui est un petit peu nerveuse
dont il se mêle les paroles du sensitive
que nous les femmes
et puis entre yves saint-martin est allé
france il ya une histoire d'amour une
histoire d'amour à laquelle nous sommes
nous étrangers nous entends propriétaire
vous en tant que public l'entraîneur en
tant qu'entraîneur c'est une histoire
entre yves saint-martin et l à tel point
que quand il rentre dans son box pour
l'avoir le mouton lui donne du coup de
tête quelles dont le mouton qu'il y
avait calé france pourquoi pas s'ils
allaient france a besoin d'un mouton
pour vivre oui comme c'est une jument
très nerveuse elle s'ennuie lui a mis un
mouton et moutons n'est pas content
quand tu moutons et jaloux disent vous
avez cette magnifique du moins de 4 ans
qui n'a pas été battu cette année qui a
gagné toutes ses courses
nous voulons voir de manière
éblouissante on te l'a remportée par
exemple le prix d'ispahan vous avez
aussi une pouliche de 3 ans qui
s'appelle paulista et qui reste sur
quatre victoires consécutives
elle sera montée par freddy head alors y
at il une préférence et ne préféreriez
vous pas voir gagner la grande jument
sentiment tellement oui bien sûr je
préfère voir gagner allez france d'abord
on l'appelait allez france pour que pour
que les étranges elle crie allez france
à l'étranger écrit aller et qu'on crie
allez france ici en france mais en
réalité pour nous ça n'a pas
d'importance me l'ont donné les ordres
sont donnés aux deux jeux qu'est de
faire le maximum pour gagner l'un ou
l'autre parce que la presse est en est
la présence du tiercé et du sweepstake
nous ne voulons pas que les parieurs
soit lésé par conséquent il est
concevable que demain 100 mètres du
poteau
il y est la ville donne-t-elle numéro 1
est à vis de l'ancien numéro 2 allée
france contre police 4 et vient de
rejeter pour l'ached / photo ddm la
batterie pas sur ça très beau d'un mot
le temps va nous mentent et qui
craint-on chez vous le plus pour vous
deux jumeaux peut-être ce contest de
loire une nourriture une autre jument et
la pouliche de la reine d'angleterre
écrire à iker a montré qu'elle n'allait
pas très bien dans le lourd je ne sais
pas si elle si le terrain lui
conviendrait bien que tu ais je voudrais
déjà être demain après midi au total
l'arc de triomphe vous savez est
toujours très proche de la roche
tarpéienne alors si vous la victoire ou
où la chute
oui mais vous avez deux grands être mais
vous a comparé